m'écouter c'est extraordinaire façon
dont vous raisonnez en ce moment
d'ailleurs moi je tiens je suis sûr que
que beaucoup de téléspectateurs 9 me
soutiendront je suis scandalisé par la
façon dont dont la télévision la radio
en général présente la situation
internationale
c'est à un cliquetis d'armes comme si
comme ci comme ça il ya des gens qui
meurent ce marché c'est ben que oui
c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'il ya des
guerres locales
mais on présente les choses comme si
demain c'était la guerre mondiale d'une
nouvelle guerre mondiale comme si
c'était l'apocalypse mais enfin il faut
quand même être sérieux quelles sont les
forces qui se met en mouvement et qui
lutte en ce moment des fosses guerrière
maintenant qu'un histoire ce n'est pas
pacifique mais c'est des forces
pacifique qui longtemps mais comment les
faire comprendre ça monsieur marché je
vous mets tout y est les gens se sont
baptisés de milliers de kilomètres logos
effik prenons les différents mouvements
mais c'est s étaient des guerriers les
hommes qui en angola au mozambique enfin
disons dans toute l'afrique ont engagé
la lutte pour l'indépendance
pour en finir avec la faim de
sous-développement et l'analphabétisme
c'est des guerriers ces gens là n'ont
cédé homme qui veut vivre comme des
hommes et non comme des bêtes
ça c'est vrai mais les cubains se guérit
mieux c'est des guerriers les délais le
peuple iranien
je n'ai rien de commun avec l'ayatollah
khomeini c'est clair mais l'ayatollah
khomeini il a réussi cette
extraordinaire tour des forces de
mobiliser son peuple sur deux objectifs
premier objectif chasser le chat qui a
les mains couvertes de sang qui a
assassiné des centaines de milliers de
bahts 2 de patriotes d'iraniens
d'iraniens le deuxième est deuxième
objectif de redonner
pays son indépendance en finir avec la
domination de l'impérialisme américain
c'est une force de guerre ou une force
de paix le peuple iranien
attendez soir exemple sur l'iran
monsieur marcher sur du rhône au 90e
rang une norme à un chalet jamais allé
au bout d'une démonstration c'est sur
votre exemple mais je sais que nombre de
questions monsieur marché monsieur prix
si vous connaissez la formule de
l'émission soyez des tentes et des
pressions mais maintenant je n'accepte
pas vous les choix vont venir
je veux répondre sur l'iran tout à
l'heure à brel à une feuille de papier
inscrivez votre question alors on a là
on met et bien je veux aller au bout de
mon réseau
vous venez de matériaux m'avait dit j'ai
vu brejnev fois j'ai vu brel piaf
il était comme vous êtes devant moi en
aussi bonne forme il a fait un exposé et
son premier exposé a duré une heure une
heure et quart nordine ce que voulait me
dire reflète un peu ce que vous avez
entendu sur la lutte contre
l'impérialisme progression non en fait
ça fait 20 ans que je discute avec vous
avec vous n'aimez pas vous ne feriez pas
comme ça vous arrive on n'en parlait
jamais comme c'est arrivé par vous
mettre dans votre petite tête que moi
aussi j'ai un cerveau et à cerveau qui
est capable de raisonner de réfléchir et
de formuler des propositions et des
appréciations la touche superbe
je ne suis pas obligé d'aller je ne vais
pas apprendre mais est ce assez allégé
dit dans ma petite tête
il faut bien je vais à l'étranger je
discute j'écoute etc
mais je suis quand même je sais je ne
suis peut-être qu'un ouvrier à vos yeux
mais je suis un militant ouvrier qui
avec mes camarades intellectuelle dans
son parti est capable de procéder à des
analyses qui tiennent debout
d'ailleurs dire sans vous achetez un
contrat d'achat donnent ces deux
brochures sait les rapports qui gonâve
que j'ai fait au congrès et la
résolution souza récupérer ça a été fait
au matin au mois de mars avril ça j'ai
lu et bien vous verrez c'est la
justification de ce qui se passe
n'empêche que le parti socialiste
puisque vous poser la question il
n'empêche que de parti socialiste
critique et condamne et je peut vous
amener gelé dans mon dossier de
nombreuses citations d'hommes du parti
socialiste il condamne les luttes
actuelles celle de manufrance et cetera
et cetera bien celle des mineurs du gard
par conséquent il est contre la lune
troisièmement le parti socialiste trouve
que giscard d'estaing a fait pas
suffisamment pour aller dans le sens de
l'alliance atlantique
alors si avec ça vous ne trouvez pas que
le parti socialiste a procédé à un
virage à droite
alors qu'est ce qui est conséquent j'ai
dans l'attitude du parti socialiste
la confirmation très clair qu' il y a
cette conjonction n'est ce pas d'un
pouvoir qui veut poursuivre et aggraver
une politique qui veut entraîner le
parti socialiste à la mise en oeuvre de
cette politique là sur la base du
consensus dont je parlais qu'ils veulent
pour cela
affaiblir le parti communiste et c'est
ce qui pose comme question fondamentale
devant des travailleurs qui veulent le
changement
le problème de se donner de donner au
parti qui luttent pour leurs
revendications et pour le vrai
changement
la force qui lui est nécessaire il voit
la question fondamentale si vous êtes
élu président la république
je marchais est-ce que vous refuserez de
parler avec ceux qui sont pas d'accord
avec vous parce que vous les critiquez
parce qu'il ya une tentative de dialogue
qu'on appelle républicain ou parme et de
dialogue
ce que vous critiquent en parlant de
consensus le c'est autre chose c'est
autre chose
ah ah oui ah oui le dialogue la
discussion mais à partir du moment où un
homme était du président de la
république ou une majorité est élu à
l'assemblée nationale il faut bien que
les élus de l'opposition discute avec
ski ça c'est pour bientôt
alors écoutez vous vous êtes vous est
terrible on essaie de comprendre vous
avez du mal
on est vraiment vraiment vous nous
expliquer pour confrères comprenait très
bien mais ça veut dire faut dire que
vous comprenez qu'en deux ans on dirais
qu'aujourd'hui on avait raison quand
même quand vous voulez ce qu'il faut le
dialogue la discussion mais nous l'avons
d'ailleurs c'est moi qui pourrait faire
reproche au président de la république
j'ai écrit deux fois pour le puits
destival il n'a jamais répondu
pauli mineurs de destival et voilà un
homme qui vient vous parler de dialogue
républicain je vous fais d'abord
observer qu'il choisit ses
interlocuteurs il dialogue avec les
socialistes
mais quand les communistes lui pose des
questions sur un problème grave concret
le problème du charbon c'est l'énergie
ce le problème d'hommes et de femmes qui
sont au fond du puits de la mine en ce
moment pour défendre cette richesse
nationale est bien le président de la
république qui a reçu ma lettre puisque
je les fais pas aimer deux nets puisque
les effets portés à l'elysée il n'a pas
cru utile de me répondre je vous fais
donc déjà observé que le dialogue pour
le républicain comme vous dites pour le
président de la république il le mène
avec des interlocuteurs choisis par lui
mais pas avec ceux qui défendent
réellement les intérêts des travailleurs
et c'est à mon avis le deuxième aspect
du dialogue
je suis pour le dialogue mais à
condition que ça se termine par quelque
chose de concret si ces départs lot pour
des parlottes ça ne m'intéresse pas mais
le dialogue pour résoudre les problèmes
posés aux travailleurs sans emploi le
dialogue pour résoudre le problème de la
cinquième semaine de congés le dialogue
pour résoudre le problème de la durée du
temps de travail
le dialogue pour résoudre le problème de
la santé et du logement de
l'enseignement et j'en passe parce
qu'ils en ont d'autres questions
oui je suis d'accord mais à condition
que ce soit à dialogue efficace pour
résoudre des problèmes ça c'est pour le
dialogue mais le consensus
sept autres choses encore ce que veut
giscard d'estaing et il ne l'a jamais
caché- d'ailleurs
regardez à la fois le contenu le ton et
le physique du président de la
république quand il apparaît à la
télévision quand il a parlé de guy
mollet
c'est tout un programme
nous tenons il a ça s'est passé le 28
juillet j'étais encore avec ma femme
devant la télévision
et quand j'ai entendu françois
mitterrand c'était à 13h quand j'ai
entendu françois mitterrand refusé de
s'engager sur l'existence d'une défense
nationale indépendante
j'ai dit à ma femme françois mitterrand
a décidé d'abandonner le programme comme
à gauche
fais les valises on rentre à paris et
nous sommes rentrés à paris et nous
sommes rentrés à paris et ses tout
débuts daoud qu'à la télévision
je me suis expliquée sur cette question
là alors moi
parce qu'enfin ken lee nous aurions
quelle allure nous aurions si nous
restions nous les bras croisés à chaque
fois qu'un peuple engage la bataille
pour le progrès social la démocratie et
socialisme et à chaque fois que
l'impérialisme intervient si nous
disions messieurs les impérialistes je
vous en prie allez-y voyons nous nous
sommes pour le principe de la non
ingérence dans les affaires intérieures
nous restons fermement attachés à ce
principe continuer de massacrer les
démocrates les patriotes les
travailleurs les intellectuels qui
veulent conquérir leur indépendance leur
souveraineté qui veulent cesser de
mourir de faim de connaître
analphabétisme si nous disions si nous
avions cette attitude passive
cette attitude des gâtines et bien nous
serions de drôles de révolutionnaire en
voyez vous messieurs
nous sommes un parti révolutionnaire et
c'est pourquoi nous nous plaçons nous
résolument aux côtés de toutes les
forces qui luttent contre l'impérialisme
pour les objectifs que je viens de dire
et chaque fois qu'il y aura des
interventions de cette nature nous nous
placerons aux côtés des forces
démocratiques qui luttent pour le
progrès voilà la position du parti est
bien alors pourquoi est ce que tout ce
raisonnement que vous venez nous tenir
longuement en expliquant bien ce que
vous pensez pourquoi justement monsieur
enrico bien les nourrir et monsieur
santiago carillo secrétaire général des
partis communistes italiens espagnols
pensent justement le contraire de vous
pour une raison simple que j'arrive pas
a comprendre a
j'arrive pas à comprendre que vous
n'ayez pas encore compris que je
m'appelle marché que lui s'appelle berne
une voix et claude s'appelle caillou
ouais mais ça c'est à s'écouter ne sais
pas je voudrais dire parce que vous avez
pas mal d'amis sic nous ne sommes pas au
music-hall or s'il vous plaît les
applaudissements c'est pour d'autres
émissions merci
non mais c'est vrai tu vas faire plus
émission avec des applaudissements ou
des sifflets je repose ma question qui
est une question importante mais je
viens de vous répondre non monsieur me
l'a reposé page des conflits n'ont pas
grave vous n'avez pas encore compris
ceux ci c'est que le parti communiste
français dans toute question quelle
qu'elle soit
détermine sa politique en toute
indépendance et que nous le faisons sans
consulter ni mon ami yann rico berning
war neolys brejnev ni santiago carillo
ni qui que ce soit
nous ne faisons en interrogeant d'abord
notre comité central qui discutent qui
détermine l'orientation et voilà comment
nous travaillons